>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> My name is Rosemary O'Neil,
and I am with the Women's Office
at the Department of State.
I've been handling women in
Afghanistan, our policy with regard
to women in Afghanistan, and one
of the great personal pleasures
that has come to me out of the
tragic situation that has transpired
in Afghanistan in the last 23 years
is meeting some absolutely wonderful
women from Afghanistan.
Their courage is truly
remarkable, and the challenges
that they have had to meet
and address and the fact
that they are now beginning to
have a voice in the rebuilding
of their country is
very, very exciting.
So we're going to meet some of those
women today and hear from them.
Sinzel Nawib [assumed spelling]
will be speaking first.
She has taught at New York
University, University of Arizona
and the University of Michigan.
She received a B.A. in history from
Kabul University, an M.A. in history
from the University of Denver, and
a Ph.D. in middle eastern studies
from the University of Arizona.
She has written extensively and
lectured on women in Afghanistan.
She's going to talk to us about
Afghan women under Marxism,
lessons for today, and
I think they say those
who do not study history
are doomed to relive it.
So very keen to listen to the
implications of what happened
in the last 20 years to
women in Afghanistan.
Sinzel?
>> Well, as Rosemary O'Neil
said, I'm talking about history.
I'm going to take you back
into history of Afghanistan
in the 20th century because I think
without understanding that part
of the history, it will be very
difficult to understand what went
on later, and particularly
the period that I'm focusing
on is the period that precedes
immediately before the Mujahideen
take over and the Taliban,
which was the period
of the Marxist rule in Afghanistan.
It would be very difficult
to condense the history
of several decades in 15
minutes, but I'll try my best.
I'll go very quickly
over everything.
We know relatively little about
how ordinary Afghans experienced
opportunities and challenges
of the Marxist era, 1978,
1992 of Afghan history
and virtually nothing
about what the period
meant to Afghan women.
Today history has swept aside the
socialist experiment with assessment
of its achievement tending
toward the negative.
It was in this 14 year period
wrote Fred Holiday that the society
and politics of the country were
brutally transformed from above
and below, leading to
the chaos of the 1990's
and which another radical
authoritarian faction,
the Taliban, came to power.
This paper will examine the politics
of the Soviet backed Afghan
Marxist regime with regards to women
and the consequences of the
Marxist policies for women
in Afghanistan and subsequent years.
Now let me tell you that this
is part of an ongoing research.
What I'm telling you today
is a part of my research.
It is based on many
interviews with men and women
who lived during the Marxist era
and also on government publications
and official documents
of the period.
In order to understand this period,
I have to give you
background of what happened.
What was the condition of
women before the Marxist?
Initial efforts to improve the
status of women in Afghanistan began
in the 1920's with King Amanullah.
Reforms initiated by King
Amanullah included the extension
of public education to girls, far
reaching changes to family law
and the unveiling of women.
I must tell you that
the emancipation woman
in Afghanistan during the
1920's was probably one
of the most revolutionary advanced
women emancipation movements
in the Middle East.
Especially the family law
of the period was so --
was considered to be so advanced
that the [inaudible]
Afghan family law to --
as a model for reforms
in Soviet Central Asia.
Ultimately, Amanullah's attempt to
improve the status of women was one
of the major causes of the
widespread clergy-backed revolts
that eventually led to his
abdication in January of 1929.
With the departure of King
Amanullah, women were again veiled
and the pace of change benefiting
women slowed down drastically.
From the early 1930's
through the 1950's,
the government undertook
a slow expansion
of girl schools in urban centers.
In 1958, the government adopted a
new cautious program to unveil women
and encourage entry into the
workplace and into public life.
In 1964, a new constitution
granted women the franchise
in equal employment opportunities.
By the 1970's, the status of women
and popular attitude toward
women changed in urban areas.
It became acceptable for women
to seek higher education,
work outside the home and take part
[inaudible] life of the community,
although old patterns of
behavior were not uprooted.
I want to emphasize on that.
And disparities between
urban and rural life began
to grow during this period.
Government policies with regard
to women provided opportunities
for education and paid work in
urban areas and prepared the ground
for popular acceptance of
women in the public arena.
So when the pro Soviet [inaudible],
the people's democratic party
of Afghanistan which is abbreviated
as the PDPA was formed in 1965,
it was able to attract to its rank
a number of female high school
and university students
in major Afghan cities.
In 1965, the center committee
of the PDPA granted permission
for the formation of the democratic
organization of Afghan women,
which is called DOAW under the
direction of Dr. [inaudible].
When the People's Democratic
Party of Afghanistan,
the PDPA gained power in a coup
on April 27, 1978, it went further
than any previous regime in the
effort to liberate women by pushing
for radical changes in the
structure of Afghan society.
To understand the politics,
the political dynamics
of the Marxist area with regard to
women in Afghanistan is necessary
to understand certain aspects
of Marxist [inaudible] theory
to which the leaders of the
People's Democratic Party
of Afghanistan adhere.
Marxist [inaudible], feminists
theory as probably most
of you know connects
the oppression of women
with the broader issue
of class struggle.
Double moral standards for
men and women according
to the Marxists originate
in class society [inaudible]
in the [inaudible] family system
that determines [inaudible]
and perpetuates the
suppression of women.
Lenin went even further
by identifying imperialism
as the main enemy of the
oppressed including women.
Leninist theorists then defined
women as the [inaudible] and argued
that women would be able to secure
full control over their lives
and reshape their destinies
only as an integral force
in the world's socialist revolution.
Guided by Marxist Leninist ideology,
the PDP [inaudible] linked
Afghanistan's backwardness
to the structure of tribal feudalism
and promoted women's
emancipation liberation --
I mean, women's emancipation
movement as central tenants
in the fight against feudalism,
capitalism and western imperialism.
In so doing, the regime, the
Marxist regime, pushed the issue
of women's emancipation to
radical extremes in Afghanistan.
Similar to -- similar in content
to measures introduced during
the 1920's by King Amanullah,
decree [inaudible] issued
in the October of 1978
by the revolutionary council
abolished forced marriages,
the exchange of women
in marriage for cash
and extravagant [inaudible].
It also limited the amount of
[inaudible] or bridal money
and set the age of
engagement in marriage at 16
for women and 18 for men.
However, unlike King Amanullah,
the PDPA leaders were careful not
to tamper with provisions of
Islamic law relating to polygamy.
The divorce law was not officially
announced, but the introduction
of family courts presided over by
women judges provided a hearing
for discontented wives and protected
their rights to divorce, alimony,
child custody and child support.
Along with the promotion of
[inaudible] number seven,
the regime launched an
aggressive literacy campaign
to strengthen its base
of support among women.
Female party members were
encouraged to fight along with men
to counter feudalism and
the negative influences
of western imperialism
in Afghanistan.
In 1984, the DOAW maintained that
the organization has succeeded
in uniting approximately 30,000
women and 669 primary organizations
and had mobilized more than 80,000
rural women in social production.
The campaign to engage women as
a revolutionary force for change
in Afghanistan, a traditional
Islamic society would entrench
tribal and patriarchal values was
found to ignite a strong reaction
from the forces of tradition.
In fact, the campaign for women's
emancipation was the impetus
for the first [inaudible]
protest against the Marxist regime
in 1978-79 resulting in the deaths
of two women activists
in [inaudible].
Dramas depicting women in
futile bondage on television
and in a flag day parade in which
female students were dancing
and chanting Marxist slogans and
waving red flags infuriated many.
Most of the female
students participating
in the parade were from Kandahar.
As it turned out, many
Kandahar fathers who had pleaded
to get their daughters admitted
at Kabul University before the
[inaudible] revolution were deeply
offended by the participation
of their daughters on
the flag day parade.
And as you know, Kandahar
is the home of the Taliban.
[Inaudible] for many Afghan Muslims,
women's liberation was associated
with [inaudible] and
the disastrous times
that had [inaudible] the country
were frequently attributed
to promiscuity associated
with emancipation of
women in Afghanistan.
So women are always
blamed for everything.
This is what happened.
Civil war combined
with Afghanistan's economic
backwardness created serious setback
to the Soviet inspired reforms.
The issue of women's rights
and women's emancipation
was deemphasized
as counter revolutionary
forces gained strength.
In 1978, a change in the leadership
of the PDPA brought
Dr. Najib Ila to power.
Realizing the gravity
of the situation,
Najib proposed national
reconciliation
and discarded all Soviet inspired
policies including efforts
to politicize women in
support of Marxist revolution.
However, Najib's efforts to
[inaudible] extreme measures adopted
by the previous regime had little
effect in changing the attitude
of the opposition groups.
The general reaction against
the feminist movement launched
by the Marxist was so strong
that many PDPA members including
Najib himself prevented their wives
from participating in public
affairs in fear of terrorist attacks
against them by opposition groups.
In a society not yet ready to see
women enjoy equal rights with men,
the PDPA's highly politicized
women's liberation movement
unleashed fundamentalist,
Islamic attitudes toward women
that were now hard to reverse.
These extreme attitudes resulted in
the torture, rape and brutal murder
in Kabul of many women alleged to
be atheist communists after the fall
of the Najib government in 1992.
Resentment against women's
emancipation was articulated
in a religious [inaudible].
Signed by 16 members of
the judiciary council
of the Mujahideen takeover.
This is not the Taliban.
And I want you to remember that
this happened before the Taliban
took over.
The verdict reads in part.
The Muslim people of Afghanistan
launched a jihad fought for 14 years
and lost numerous lives in order
to re-establish divine
ordinances in the country.
Now by the grace of the almighty,
our Islamic country is free
from the bondage of
the atheist rule.
We strongly demand immediate
enforcement [inaudible].
We recommend that women
be banned from television,
radio and government offices and
that all girl schools which are
in reality the [inaudible] and
adulteress practices be closed down.
This verdict was the signal for
the Taliban to exclude women
from public life and push
them back into the home.
Some lessons may be drawn from
the experience of the Marxist era.
The most important initiative of
the Marxist period with regard
to the status of women was
to make education available
to women of all ages and classes.
The PDPA's literacy campaign
if successful would have improved
the position of women even
in the remote villages
of Afghanistan.
The aspects of the literacy
campaign of the Marxist era
which were not offensive to Afghan
culture might serve as a model
for the expansion of education
for women in Afghanistan.
Also, significant was the
regime's efforts to empower women
by teaching them organizational
skills and encouraging them
to be involved in Afghan politics
and become active members
of Afghan civil society.
On the other hand,
however, the experience
of the Marxist people [inaudible]
illustrates the adverse effects
of combining women issues
with [inaudible] propaganda
rooted in un-Islamic ideology.
The highly politicized women's
emancipation campaign based
on the ideology of class struggle
propelled women into the forefront
of the clash between ideological
radicalism of the Marxist
and the traditional Muslim
indigenous society ultimately
resulting in a serious setback
in the liberation of
women in Afghanistan.
The Marxist experience in
Afghanistan has been characterized
as the failure of revolution
from above.
It represents a case of
a weak state attempting
to enforce revolutionary
changes from the top,
and this has happened
twice in [inaudible].
Twice during the 20th century in
Afghan history, once in the 1920's
and then during the Marxist era
in the 1980's, the state attempted
to bring revolutionary
changes in the status of women.
In both instances, the
mobilization of women was met
with strong opposition
by reactionary forces
and created a major backlash.
The struggle for women's rights in
Afghanistan is an ongoing process.
I believe strongly in the power
and the potentials of Afghan women.
However, now that a window of hope
has opened to the Afghan women
to assert the proper place in
Afghan society, it's important
for the advocates of women's
rights to pay heed to the outcome
of the radical campaigns of
the 1920's and the 1980's.
Two decades of war
resulted in the total demise
of the modernization efforts
of the earlier periods
and re-entrenched traditional
values with regard to women.
It would seem prudent to
establish a set of priorities
and proceed incrementally
and also proceed with a plan
that have long term effects on the
status of women of Afghanistan.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> All right.
Well, I'm going to be talking
about women's state and development
in Afghanistan, although I think I
should also have called this women's
state, the international community
and development in Afghanistan.
The country is, as you are aware,
currently owing a political
transition in the context
of poverty, under development
and infrastructural
devastation through war.
The challenges of reconstruction
are quite daunting
and uncertainty remains about the
nature of governance in Afghanistan.
It's similarly unclear how women
will fare given the continuing
warfare and the lack of
clarity women and gender issues
on the part of leadership.
There have been some positive
developments since the bond meetings
of last year but some areas
of concern [inaudible].
Now the type of state and
legal system that emerges
from the present transitional period
will determine the extent and manner
in which women's interests
and women's needs are
addressed in the country.
Conversely, how genders are
addressed will reveal much
about the nature of the
governance structures,
the vision of the country's
leadership and the national identity
that is to be constructed
in post Taliban Afghanistan.
Because in Afghanistan as elsewhere,
the woman question has been tied
to competing concepts of national
identity and has been central
to battles between traditionalists
and modernizers through most
of modern Afghan history.
We've heard from Dr. Sinzel
Nawib's brilliant exposition
about the difficulties of the
Marxist era, and I will touch upon
that very, very briefly because
in my work I have argued that in
at least three periods during
the 20th century, women's rights
in Afghanistan have been very
highly politicized but also central
to the political conflicts
in the country,
and the first period is the
1920's, which Dr. Nawib referred
to when efforts by reformers,
nationalists and modernizers
to improve the status of women
to establish an education system
and to modernize the
economy and society met
with the fierce resistance
of traditionalists
and the [inaudible],
the Islamic clergy.
The second period was
the 1970's and the 1980's
when two opposing movements,
one Marxist modernizing
and the other Islamist
traditionalist clash
and fought a long and bloody war
over divergent political agendas,
cultural understandings
and conceptions
of women's rights and women's place.
And in the 1990's, the third
period, the Taliban gave new meaning
to this concept of social
exclusion, which is a term
that has become very fashionable
in European social theory
and development --
international development circles
when it instituted
draconian policies
against not only women's
public participation
but their very visibility.
So the question is for
those of us who do sort
of a historical sociology, why has
there been such limited progress
on women's rights including
women's literacy
and educational attainment
in Afghanistan?
Why has the question of women been
so vexed in modern Afghan history?
Well, I have argued in my
previous work that the advancement
of women's rights in Afghanistan
has been historically constrained
by three factors.
First is the patriarchal
nature of gender
and social relations deeply embedded
in the traditional communities
in Afghanistan and expressed
also in the tribal code
of the [inaudible]
called the [inaudible].
The second factor is the
existence of a weak central state,
which has been unable since at least
the beginning of the 20th century
to implement modernizing
programs and goals in the face
of ethnic divisions, entrenched
rural interests and tribal futilism.
And these two factors
are interconnected
for the state's weakness
is correlated with a strong
if fragmented society
that has been resistant
to state bureaucratic expansion,
civil authority, regulation,
monopoly of the means of
violence and extraction.
That is, the business
of modern states.
And the third constraining factor
has been opportunistic intervention
by neighboring countries
and the United States
and until the 1930's Great Britain,
which served to intensify tribal
or ethnic conflict, stall or
setback socioeconomic development
and increase women's insecurity.
So these three factors I
have argued behind the defeat
of the modernizing efforts of
King Amanullah in the 1920's,
the incapacity of the governments
during the [inaudible] era 1933
to 1973, and the defeat
of the Democratic Republic
of Afghanistan's attempt to
implement a wide ranging program
for land reform, women's rights and
social development in the 1980's.
The patriarchal social
structure, ethnic divisions
and tribal futilism also
explained the disintegration
of the Mujahideen government
1996 and the inability
of both the Mujahideen and the
Taliban to undertake reconstruction
and development, let
alone women's rights.
[Inaudible] most of the
20th century, therefore,
a patriarchal social structure,
the absence of a strong centralized
and modernizing state and
conflictual international relations,
the great gain, the cold
war, regional rivalries,
these factors relegated
Afghan women to a status
that could only generously
be called second citizenship.
And during the long reign
of [inaudible] for example,
the country did experience
relative peace and stability
but very little social
development took place as we heard.
The tiny elite in Kabul managed
to insert a gender equality clause
in the 1964 constitution and four
women joined the new parliament then
next year.
But by the late 1970's, fully 94
percent of women were illiterate.
Moreover, 89 percent of village,
primary and secondary schools were
for boys while only 11 percent
of schools were for girls.
World bank data show that in
1981 the secondary school gross
enrollment rate for girls was only
4.5 percent compared with 33 percent
in Iran and 7.9 percent in Pakistan.
And I have a graph that really
dramatically illustrates the extent
to which Afghanistan in the
late 1970's and in 1980 sort
of on the eve of the
Marxist revolution
and immediately afterwards was
really very, very much behind
on every socioeconomic indicator
compared to their neighbors Pakistan
and especially compared to Iran.
This graph shows comparative
statistics
on educational enrollments
in the three countries
in 1981 using world bank
statistics and data.
The variables are primary
school pupils percent female,
primary education teachers
percent female
and secondary school
enrollment percent gross female.
The short bar is Afghanistan.
The middle bar is Pakistan and the
tallest bar, of course, is Iran.
So you can get a sense of how much
further behind Afghanistan was
compared to its neighbors as
late as 1981 or '78, '79-80.
So the results of this
situation were that apart
from a very small albeit it very
talented urban female elite,
the vast majority of Afghan women
experienced social exclusion,
illiteracy, poor health
and subordination.
And Afghanistan did lag behind
its neighbors for quite some time.
But even so, some progress was
made as Sinzel Nawib pointed
out in girl school enrollments
between 1981 and 1991.
That is to say during the
period of Marxist rule.
And the female proportion
of the tertiary level was
especially remarkable.
There we go.
Okay. As you can see between 1980 --
I should point out that statistics
are very less than precise
in many developing countries
and especially in a country
like Afghanistan where the most
scientific surveys have been carried
out with only great, great
difficulty and very infrequently.
So these are estimates, but we
have to deal with what we have.
As you can see between 1981 and
1991, primary school enrollment
and in particular the percentage
that was female almost doubled.
So there was some progress even
though there was a very nonconducive
environment, i.e. the
international civil conflict
that took place during
most of the 1980's.
And the secondary school pupils,
the percent female was
32.2 percent in 1991.
So this also gives you
a sense of the progress.
The other interesting thing is that
according to the 1989 UN report
on Afghanistan by the
UN special [inaudible],
Dr. Felix Amicora [assumed
spelling], and he was in Kabul
at the same time that I was there
in January, February of 1989.
His report mentions that there were
seven higher education institutes
in Kabul with a total of
15,319 students of both sexes
and the medical institute
under the ministry
of public health had really
integrated a lot more students.
For example, a total of 18,000
students in 1989 compared
with a total enrollment
of 7000 in '77-78.
And in 1989, Kabul University
had about 7000 students
of which 65 percent were women.
So the next time you
hear the statistics
that before the Taliban
came to power,
40 percent of civil servants
were women and 60 percent
of the university students were
female, it should be pointed
out that this was the era
before the Mujahideen,
i.e. during the communist
era, not in the early 1990's,
but during the communist era.
Thank you.
All right, well let's look ahead a
little bit towards reconstruction
and development with women
and how current policies
and laws might be able to meet
what researchers within the field
of gender and development define
as women's practical needs
and their strategic
gender interests.
And of course practical needs have
to do with basic issues of literacy
and health and water and
shelter and perhaps a second tier
of educational attainment and so on,
and the strategic gender
interests have to do with helping
to realize women's equality,
autonomy and empowerment,
and of course this has to
be regarded as holistic.
That is to say without meeting
women's basic needs, you can't help
to realize women's
strategic interests but also
that meeting women's
strategic interests,
that is to say attaining
equality, autonomy
and empowerment also requires
a conducive legal environment.
The difference between Afghan women
today and Afghan women in the 1970's
and 1980's when they were
really more or less neglected
by the international community was
that today they are
enjoying the benefit
of a new international environment
that really places a high premium
on gender equality and
women's participation,
and this is partly a legacy
of the UN decade for women,
but it's partly a legacy of what
we may call global feminism,
which really came into its own
after the 1985 Nairobi conference,
and it's sort of no accident that by
the time the Taliban came to power
in 1996, global feminism was in full
swing, and it became the target.
The Taliban regime became the
target of a highly mobilized
and organized transnational
feminist movement with a commitment
to the universality of women's
human rights and the benefit
of technological know how,
and we heard a little bit
about this during the internet
discussion earlier today.
But the question is will this new
global environment favoring women's
rights influence planning,
policies and resource allocations
for a post Taliban Afghanistan in a
way that benefits women and girls?
Well, certainly the transnational
feminist movement can be relied upon
to monitor the situation, to
advocate and promote the rights
of women and girls and so on,
but the question still is whether
post Taliban Afghanistan will adopt
the legal and policy frameworks
conductive to the realization
and expansion of women's
needs and rights.
One area of concern pertains to
the legal frameworks that are
to be decided upon by
the next [inaudible].
The bond agreement that took
place last year stipulated
that the new constitution and the
legal framework should be drafted
"in accordance with Islamic
principles, international standards,
the rule of law and
Afghan legal traditions."
That's quite a broad remit,
and we can expect some disagreement
among the political forces
over the mixed and hierarchy
of international secular [inaudible]
traditional practices and codes.
And the legal framework that
[inaudible] which as I said is
yet unclear will be
able to determine
and shape women's interests
and needs.
The challenges are very
daunting and my last --
And my last overhead
illustrates again some
of the daunting challenges
[inaudible] most basic needs
of Afghan women and men and girls.
So what are some of the
major needs of Afghan women?
In an article that I published in
the Journal of World Development
in 1994, I identified some of
the major concerns and the needs
at the time, and they're actually
still quite pertinent and salient.
What are they?
Literacy, basic and formal
education, and the closing
of the gender gap and access
to educational attainment.
Healthcare.
There are serious gender
gaps and special problems
such as maternal mortality,
infant and child mortality, TB,
mental illness, drug
addiction and so on.
There needs to be activities
and therapies for women
and girls suffering
war-related traumas.
There need to be special programs
for widows and disabled women,
vocational training, rehabilitation,
[inaudible] projects,
skills training and upgrading,
refresher courses for those
who have been unemployed
for some time.
[Inaudible], handy crafts,
food processing enterprising
and [inaudible] manufacturing,
jewelry.
A lot of these sorts of things
that women can be integrated into
and of course the legal
rights for urban woman.
And I was pleased that in the
Afghan women's action plan
which was decided upon last
March and will be coordinated
by the Ministry for Women's Affairs,
some of these priority areas
have been delineated and four
in particular were prioritized,
and they are advocacy
and legal aid training.
Oh sure. Okay.
Literacy, widows and orphans
and reproductive health.
So just to wrap up, I'm pleased
to hear that the state department,
and I'm grateful to Rosemary O'Neil
for making this information
available to me,
has designed some valuable
projects for Afghan women.
Some of these projects are ongoing
and some of them are proposed.
And I think we have to wait
and see what the extent
of the implementation of
these projects will be
and also what the impact
of these projects will be.
I should also point out that
there are some serious problems
with funding.
A total of $4.5 billion was
allocated for the reconstruction
of Afghanistan and a number
of different countries were
to contribute to this fund
but as recently as last month
of the 1.8 billion which was
supposed to be allocated this year,
fully 1.2 billion is
still outstanding.
So many Afghans are very concerned,
and Afghan women are very
concerned about two things.
One, about the low level of funding
that has been made
available thus far and two,
the whole question of security.
So one can only hope
that women's needs
and rights will be prioritized,
that sufficient levels
of funding will be forthcoming
and there has been some very
serious disagreements over the level
and extent of funding, and also that
Afghan women themselves will be able
to -- and I'm sure they will
be able to make a strong case
for why their needs and their
rights need to be prioritized
and fully integrated into
any programs and strategies
for reconstruction and development
and peace building in Afghanistan.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much, Rosemary.
Thank you all for coming.
I know you must be all very
tired at the end of the long day,
so I'll basically focus my
remarks today on the emergence
of civil society, its
role and its function
in Afghanistan, my home country.
Although I focus my remarks
on women with whom --
Afghan women with whom I've
worked with almost two decades,
I also want to note that my
organization, Refugee Women
and Development [inaudible]
has worked extensively
with war affected women and their
male counterparts in various parts
of the world, and I do want to
stress that although we are a women
and development organization working
with women who have been affected
by war and conflict, we also
include men because especially
in Islamic society such
as the one I originate
from is extremely important
to work in that context.
Now let me move on briefly to
talk about [inaudible] programs
and a little bit on the
history of our work.
We have so far in the past
23 years provided training
and technical assistance to hundreds
of civil society organizations led
by women and their
male counterparts,
and we have basically
strengthened and focused
on strengthening the independent
sector, transition from war
to peace and to democracy.
We remain convinced
that the existence
of strong civil society is
essential to monitor the functions
of political institutions in
a democracy, especially one
that is transitioning and emerging
from war and emerging democracy.
With regard to Afghan women,
we have worked extensively
by providing training, technical
assistance and small grants
to help upgrade the
capacities of women,
community grassroots organizers who
have organized in Pakistan and Iran
and most recently of
course in Afghanistan.
We help women with their networking
opportunities, and we make sure
that women are empowered to lead
efforts which promote changes
in their human rights conditions
and in the conditions in general
and to basically serve as agents of
change and to participate actively
in the reconstruction of
Afghanistan and a civil society.
Our philosophy basically is --
although I myself am a
product of the Afghan war
and have worked extensively with
my [inaudible] in other parts
of the world, I do not believe
in basically taking our
[inaudible] models to any situation
because it does [inaudible]
particularly
in the case of Afghanistan.
We made sure that when we worked
with the civil society leaders
and organizers, we made sure
that we listened to them,
we consult with them extensively
to basically assess
what their needs are
and basically what their [inaudible]
and then develop models that's
appropriate and meets their needs
and which is in the context
of their own aspirations.
We believe very much in empowerment
and inclusion of Afghan women
in the reconstruction of Afghan
society and to accomplish this,
you basically have -- we think it's
important for women to have access
to information, organization
management and leadership skills.
Women -- Afghan women I've
worked with basically tell me
that it's important for
them to work in unison
with other indigenous Afghan groups
and international organizations,
and they are telling me
constantly that they need regional
and international linkages,
particularly with women
in the Muslim world
and Muslim society
because they need information on
Islamic humanitarian principles
because this is the way -- this is
the information they need in order
to use those -- that
information and those models
to progress in their own societies.
We have worked consistently
and pursued two aims.
One, to rebuild the shattered civil
society institutions in Afghanistan
by extending our programs to war
affected Afghans in Afghanistan
and across the border as refugees
and internally displaced people,
and we assist Afghan community
grassroots organizations operating
in Iran and Pakistan to basically
relocate within Afghanistan.
So far, we have trained
-- we're an organization
that has worked extensively
across gender
and across sectarian
and ethnic affiliations.
We have trained and worked with 90
Afghan civil society institutions
from various ethnic representations
and we provided small grants
to 13 Afghan [inaudible]
to support their projects.
And we have worked with
many groups who were working
at the Taliban clandestinely to
help women to continue their work
to provide education
and skills training
to women who are in Afghanistan.
Let me state that during
the past two decades
in Afghanistan military
regimes have focused --
their focus has been on
war and the war economy,
which has led to the breakdown
of the Afghan social fabric
which has kept the
voices of tolerant
and democratic-minded Afghans muted.
In essence, for the past 23 years,
the story in Afghanistan has been
that of empowerment, but empowerment
of the communist, the holy warriors
and then the empowerment of the
Taliban, but nowhere has the story
of the empowerment of the
Afghan people taken place
and the international community
must empower war affected Afghans
to rebuild their economies and it's
time to finance Afghan led efforts
to promote peace and building
of democratic civil institutions
to balance the powerful
political institutions.
Now let me move on and
to talk a little bit
about the impact for Afghanistan.
We all know that the war has
had a very serious impact
on both the social, political
and physical structure
of the Afghan society.
Our society has been ravaged
by the 23 years of conflict .
Two million Afghan
lives have been lost.
One million land mine handicapped.
12 million women living in
object poverty and according
to the human development index
of the United Nations
Development Program,
average life expectancy is 46 years,
a mortality rate of 25.7 percent
for children under 5 years old and
an illiteracy rate of 64 percent
and Afghan ranks among the most
destitute war damaged countries
in the world in terms of human
development and an average
of 46 women die every
day in Afghanistan.
Rampant poverty has long
characterized Afghanistan,
and 1996 takeover by
the Taliban faction
of religious extremists is the most
recent assault in a long history
of oppressive regimes, and this is
something that I must underscore.
Under the Taliban, women in
particular were subjected
to severe form of government
and deprivation
of their basic human rights.
Today, approximately 1.2 million
Afghan refugees still reside
in Pakistan, 1.4 million in Iran
and an estimated 1.7
million refugees Afghans
who are displaced internally
within the borders of Afghanistan.
As in most war conditions,
the majority of the refugees
and the internal displaced people
are women and their children,
and the magnitude of this
tragedy is so mind boggling
that few outside Afghanistan can
conceptualize an approach let alone
a solution.
And here is where the problem
lies, and if we don't take
that into consideration, I
don't think the solutions
from the outside will work
and basically affecting change
and bringing sustainable democracy
and development in Afghanistan.
Let me move on to outline a few
basic issues that's affecting the
status of women.
The status of women I'm
sure as most of you know
in Afghanistan what ranks
amongst the worst in the world.
The statistics indicate that one
in every woman dies in childbirth
or pregnancy related
complications every 30 minutes.
70 percent of all diagnosed
tuberculosis cases occur in women.
This is the highest
TB rate in the world.
Literacy is among the
lowest in the world.
It is estimated that 80 percent
of the Afghan women cannot read
or write, and women are
the poorest of the poor
and in fact they are leading
what we call in the field
of development the
feminization of poverty
and the feminization
of forced migration.
Maternal and infant mortality rates
among the highest in the world.
An Afghan child is 25 times more
likely to die before the age of five
and 300,000 women -- sorry,
children die each year
from preventable diseases and
although there are no statistics
on mental health, we know that women
are highly traumatized by the impact
of war, and suicide rates
are rapidly on the rise
and obviously women are
amongst the most undernourished.
And the demographics
of Afghanistan is
such that it's a society that's
largely composed of women
who are taking charge of
not only their own lives
but an estimated one million
children who are orphan,
the elderly, the handicapped
while they themselves are heavily
traumatized, malnourished
and under supported.
Despite these daunting challenges,
Afghan women have demonstrated
remarkable abilities
to transcend their image as
victims and instead excel
as resources for development.
This is something that I
would like to underscore.
I'll move on now how they have
demonstrated their ability given
these daunting challenges.
The NGO movement and
[inaudible] civil society,
how did it come about?
We know that the past 23 years of
war we have not had a government,
and we have had military regimes
and obviously the Afghan people
were heavily impacted by a lack
of government that will
provide basic services
that normally you would have
access to during times of peace.
So Afghan women basically realize
that they had to take matters
in their own hands,
so they basically organized their
communities in exile in Iran
and Pakistan and also
inside Afghanistan
and during the time of the Taliban.
To provide the very
critically needed human services
in their communities, they provided
education, health, human rights
and social services to
their own communities.
And they were doing so --
at great risk to themselves
and their families, and the many
Afghans and the scores of Afghans
that are living in these
conditions [inaudible] for democracy
and democratic institution building
and civil society for the future
of Afghanistan lies within them.
So therefore it's imperative
that technical assistance
and resources be committed
to the human
and the [inaudible]
resource development
of the indigenous Afghan
women community leaders
and their male counterparts.
However, so far the efforts to
focus on the independent sector
in Afghanistan has been very
short term and sporadic.
We have looked at the situation
in Afghanistan as an emergency.
All this has existed
for the past 23 years
and obviously short
term development schemes
and emergency relief
schemes are very different.
If you want to really impact
change, it's important
that a long term policy and
activities that long term
that builds the capacity
and the skills
of the Afghan people is
imperative to affect change.
We cannot do development assistance
and rebuilding the [inaudible]
social fabric of the Afghan society
through short term projects.
And you must support
the embryonic burgeoning
of the Afghan civil society
institutions because without
that we will not be
empowering the Afghan people.
What do we need now
to bring a change?
First of all, it is
important for us to realize
that because there is
emphasis on the gender issues
and development issues
in Afghanistan,
we are very pleased to see that.
However, the implementation
strategies and the vision that goes
with this policy really is lacking.
We must make sure that we establish
a structure that emphasizes
in building the capacities and
empowering the Afghan people rather
than bringing the kind of
approaches that really don't work
within the Afghan society.
We need to speak and to consult
and actively involve Afghan
women themselves in the planning
and the design and the
implementation of all efforts
to build the fabric
of the Afghan society
and particularly the
independent sector.
So far, too much emphasis
has been paid
on building the governance
structures in Afghanistan
and the political institutes.
I know that it's very important
that in a new democracy,
one that is emerging from
conflict, it's important to do that,
but however, if you neglect
the civil society sector,
we are making a grave mistake.
So there needs to be more emphasis
on the civil society
sector and the NGO sector.
However, we need to make sure that
we understand who the NGO's are,
who the credible NGO's
are, who are the leaders
and how do we provide training
and assistance and small grants?
But we also need to make sure that
we provide a system that it monitors
and provides -- establishes
transparency and accountability
of these grassroots
organizations that are emerging
to provide services
in their communities.
Now let me conclude my
remarks by saying that we
as Afghan women are very
pleased that the window
of opportunity has opened
for us, and we have hope,
but we need to make sure that the
Afghan people are given a voice
and they are empowered because
I think that the best solution
to bring to the war on terrorism
and to waging war on intolerance
in Afghanistan lies
within the Afghan people,
and the Afghan people
are very tolerant minded
and civil society minded.
However, so far we have
not heard their voices.
We have heard the very extreme right
and extreme left voices emerging
from Afghanistan, and it's time
for us to dispel those myths
and realize what is the true
nature of the Afghan people?
So educate yourselves about
who the Afghan people are
and what their needs are in order
to bring sustainable democracy
and peace in Afghanistan.
It's imperative that it's time to --
that we actually empower the
Afghan people and give a voice
to the Afghan [inaudible] 67 percent
of the Afghan population
right now is women
and without them we
will not succeed.
I thank you for your attention.
I'd be happy to take
questions later on.
>> Would like to share with you
some experiences since I've been
in Afghanistan since December 26 --
22, the transfer of power
the day power was transferred
from [inaudible].
Lots of major changes
have occurred since 1999
when I was in Kabul like music.
You can actually hear
music on the streets now.
Kids are going back to school.
There is -- shops are all opened up.
There's actually life where before
during the Taliban when I arrived
in Kabul, it felt like the soul of
the city is taken out of its body
and people were just
sitting around doing nothing.
And of course women couldn't go out.
We even have some traffic lights now
and occasionally a car
stops when the light is red.
And if they do stop,
we have a traffic jam
and then you can't get out of it.
There are 25 embassies
opened in Kabul.
Peacekeepers are there.
So a lot of wonderful things are
going on, but we must realize
that we cannot cover up
scars with cosmetics,
and we need to work
seriously on healing.
We at Afghanistan are focusing
on healing through education,
allowing the kids to
write, to paint.
You should see the pictures
that the children paint.
It was much easier to defeat
the Taliban than it is to deal
with the legacy they left behind.
And that is the emotional
state of the Afghan people.
I opened a [inaudible] school for
girls when I was in Kabul in 1999
and the Taliban came and beat them
up until their hands were bleeding.
They beat up their
teacher in front of them,
but they never stopped coming.
They just found other
strategies to come to school
so that the Taliban don't see them.
They came one by one, wrapped with
their books with the cover of Quran,
and they came with
all kinds of ideas.
UNICEF summary reports says
that total of learning space
in Afghanistan right now is 6784.
That means the formal and
nonformal education --
and nonformal education
are the schools that --
are schools but they're
not registered
with the ministry right now.
There are 4686 formal schools, and
there are 2098 nonformal schools,
but they couldn't really survey
all of the nonformal schools.
I think there are a lot
more than just 2000.
And there are total teachers
73,074, female teachers are 20,566
and male teachers are 52,507.
It's only in Kabul where female
teachers exceed male teachers
by 30 percent.
The biggest problem right
now is that there --
generation of 12 to
16-year-old girls who are sitting
at first, second and third grade.
48 percent of the students
currently are at first grade.
14 percent are at second grade.
11 percent are at third grade.
Eight percent are at fourth grade,
two percent are at eighth grade.
I'm sorry, yeah, eighth grade
and then one percent are
at ninth, 11th and 12th grades.
So the size of the 12th grade
classes are very, very small.
Sanitation and water are
the two major problems.
48 percent of all schools
have access to water.
And only 25 percent have access to
sanitation facilities or toilets.
Now I'm going to share with you some
slides so we could have a picture
of what the schools will
look like as I'm talking.
This gives you just an idea of
what the city kind of looks like.
There's a river.
There was a river.
It's dried up.
They have opened up a market
inside the river called Titanic.
They like the movie, Titanic so much
that now they could do this,
they called it Titanic.
So this just kind of gives you a
general picture of the [inaudible]
that building, that high rise,
that's the only high
rise in the city.
On the left is the
communication ministry.
And the next one.
Okay, this is one of the schools
that we're supporting in Kabul.
It's called [inaudible].
It has 8345 students, 2732 of them
are girls, 5613 of them are boys.
They have 80 teachers, 80 women
teachers and 70 male teachers.
Most of the kids are learning
in very strange facilities.
This is a bus.
Can you go to the next slide?
These are these buses, the skeleton
of buses that they're sitting in,
and it's extremely hot because
summer is very hot in Kabul,
and they're cramped in there.
They don't have any tables.
And this is -- the
top is just the --
they cut off the side of the buses.
This is the bus.
It looks like it's two
stories, but it's just one.
And there are no chairs, nothing
even to put under their feet.
And this is another school
in a different part of Kabul.
There are 1173 students in this.
This is a big house that
somebody donated to the school.
And there is 556 girls and 617
boys, and they have 52 teachers.
So these are the classrooms.
They do have some chairs
and tables that was provided
by an organization for them.
But most of them are
sitting on the floor.
Now this is another school that
some German organization I think are
taking care of the building for
them, but it's a huge school.
They have 10,800 students.
We went mostly to this particular
school because all of the classes,
the under classes,
underground classes that we had,
the kids are sitting
on these classes.
They did very well, the ones
who were at third grade,
they are in fifth grade and the
ones that were on fifth grade,
they're on seventh grade.
They're doing much better
than the other kids.
But they still don't
have chairs and tables.
This particular school
are mostly girls.
They have 6480 girls and
only 3620 boys in the school.
That's the same school.
These are one of our students.
They're sitting in the hallways.
And this is eighth grade,
and you can see how much
older these girls are
than regular eighth graders
that would be on eighth grade.
And they're sitting -- they have
20 classes conducting outside.
This is one of our students.
You have to reverse it.
This is a 12th grade
at the same school.
They don't have enough chairs,
and the girls are over 20.
Okay now this is [inaudible].
This is a different
province in Afghanistan
about 1.5 hour away from Kabul.
They're planning on building
an international airport
in [inaudible].
This is -- it's a very small
little village in [inaudible].
It's 430 years old
this little village.
They have never had school.
This is the first time that some
teachers are coming back from Kabul
and they have gathered
some students,
and they have put together
this very small little school
for girls and boys.
This is the classroom, and they
have only first and second grade.
These are these --
Beautiful kids.
Nike. I just wanted [inaudible].
They're just amazing kids.
The same school.
But they're just so happy.
They don't have very much.
They don't have chairs or books
and notebooks or anything.
They don't even have much to
eat, but they're very happy.
Now this is [inaudible]
Valley from [inaudible].
It's just a beautiful,
beautiful area
with this river runs through it.
We have had our projects
in [inaudible] since 1999.
I couldn't go back to Kabul so we
started our projects in [inaudible]
because that was the
only place we could work.
So we do have a school being
built right now for girls,
and we are supporting an
orphanage, a small orphanage
of 30 kids in [inaudible].
So kids just go by the
river and play in the water.
Believe it or not, I found a beach.
This was sand, and these kids
naturally knew what to do,
and they just went and laid by
the sand and they were playing
with a tank in the river.
This is the streets of [inaudible].
This is a school that I visited
in 2000 when I was in [inaudible].
Recently UNICEF has
gone and it was nothing.
The kids didn't even have all this.
There were only two rooms, and the
kids were all sitting on the floor,
but now UNICEF has put
up these tents for them,
and they have these classrooms
under the tents with somewhat
of a bench at least to sit on.
315 students.
It's a very small class, and the
kids were painting their blackboard.
264 of these students are all
girls, and they only have 54 boys.
Now this -- these slides from this
slide on will just show scenes
of what women do in Kabul right now.
This is a woman who's holding the
-- she's the police on the street.
Women are actually
working on the street next
to men, fixing up the roads.
And these are not very young.
I asked them how old they
are, and one of the --
the one to the right
said, "I must be 50."
Most women don't know their age,
but they think 50 is very old.
This is a [inaudible] bakery.
These are mostly widows.
Their children go to school.
They work from 4:30 in the morning
until 4:30 in the afternoon.
Those who have daughters
12 and 13 years old,
they don't let their daughters go
to school because the daughters have
to take care of the
siblings, younger siblings
because the mothers have
to come and work here.
They don't really have a choice.
The refugee women who were coming
back and settling in this one area
where all the houses are destroyed,
she was baking bread outside.
But she was very happy that
she can do this at home.
These are refugees returning,
settling in these destroyed homes.
There are no windows, no doors.
I'm not sure what's going to happen
to them once it gets
cold next month.
It's going to be raining
and freezing.
I don't know.
They don't know what to do.
They were just going to
live day by day and see.
Same refugees in the
destroyed homes.
They're just so happy and playful,
and they don't really
have very much,
no food, no clothing, no nothing.
It's extremely hot, but she
just loved to pose in front
of the camera, and she
followed me around.
Children, boys, most of the boys
after school go to make money
because they are the
supporters of the family now.
They either do shoe polishing
or selling water, washing cars
or sewing odds and ends
because they have to make money.
I met this one little
girl where I passed by.
One day she was sitting
on the street begging,
and then the next day when I
passed by, she was laying down,
and it was extremely hot.
So I asked the driver to turn
around and I stopped next to her,
and I went and bought
her some juice.
And I came by and some
guys approached me
and said, "Don't worry about her.
These people, this is a trick.
Don't give her money."
And I thought it's fascinating
that these kids learn
tricks to get more money.
She was making noise
so that she's crying
and maybe people will pay her
more money, and then as we left,
she got up and she was
walking and then we turned
around again, and I called her.
I said, "What are you doing here?"
And she said, "I'm
collecting [inaudible]."
I asked her how old you are?
She's nine years old.
She looked -- her skin looked like
she's at least 40, and she said --
I said, "How come you're
collecting [inaudible] here?"
And she said, "Well my father was
killed in the last bombing of U.S.,
and I've been doing
this for two months now
because I have a small brother,
and there's no job for my mother."
I give her a bunch of money, and
I said, "Let's go to your house.
Can I visit your Mom?"
She said, "No, I don't want to go
home because my mother will be mad
at me because I come home early."
So most of the children are
either begging out on the streets
or working to earn about $2 to $3 a
day to survive for the whole family,
and they don't have much to
eat at the end of the day.
They just eat bread and tea and
maybe sugar if they have it.
But these kids are very happy.
I mean, this is what surprises me
that they just have such a spirit.
This is our computer
center in Kabul.
Unfortunately, I don't
have a better slide.
If you go to our site,
www.afghanistan [inaudible].com,
you'll see other pictures of
the organization and our work
and this is a computer
center that we have in Kabul.
We have many students.
It's actually filled up.
It's -- what keeps us working
and going is the spirit
of the Afghan people and the
commitment and the passion
that the kids have for
learning and knowledge
and it really makes me work
more, want to work more.
I mean, the fact that they came --
it was in the middle of the winter
in December, and all these kids
were coming to school for --
we normally don't have schools in
the winter time because it's very,
very cold, but they were preparing
for the regular school
year for March.
And these kids came and most schools
had no chairs, nothing on the floors
and they were sitting
there freezing,
but schools were filled
up with kids.
It was amazing.
How -- where they got all of
that commitment, I have no idea.
Okay. I'm finished actually.
I just wanted to tell you a
short story about this orphanage
that we have in [inaudible] area.
This is what encourages me
to work in Afghanistan is
that we have 30 orphans, and when I
asked them this last time two weeks
ago what do they want
me to bring for them?
They said satellite dish
because we want to talk
to you when you're there.
And we want to know what other
fun things is over there,
and we want to know
more about there.
There is like -- they
didn't really know where,
but they knew that there is
this other place that I go to
and I come back and other
people go and come back,
and there are other things
that they just want to know.
And then when I ask them what do
you want to become when you grow up?
This 80-year-old said the president.
And one very major concern for
me is that there are still areas
in Afghanistan like
[inaudible] which is an area
where it's very difficult to get to
and they have not had any schools
in [inaudible] but a lot
of [inaudible] have
found shelter there,
and they have only
[inaudible] schools.
I was trying to go there this time.
Unfortunately, there was not
enough time and people thought
that I shouldn't go
because it's too dangerous,
and this will may become another
home for the fundamentalists.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Story of Afghan women is
the story of great courage
and resiliency and we thank you for
your moving presentations today.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.